as we ponder the mysteries of time this
is the one lecture in which
we'll allow ourselves to get a little
philosophical and by that i don't mean
we'll just sort of sit back and ponder
how awesome it all
is and reflect upon the majesty of time
and space
what i mean is we're gonna think about
the problem from a philosophical
perspective from the rigorous
academic discipline of philosophy now
there is of course a long-standing
relationship
between physics and philosophy or
between science and philosophy
more generally there is let's say a
usually friendly
rivalry the two disciplines are a little
bit different they have absolutely
different aims
but their subject matters often overlap
and the study of time
is one where the philosophical
perspective is absolutely
helpful even to physicists like myself
what philosophers try to do
is to really understand the logical
inner workings of something
physicists like myself are often very
happy
just to get a theory that works a theory
that makes
sense is a little bit too much to ask
sometimes
and you might think this is not possible
but we have it all the time
quantum mechanics is a great example of
a theory that doesn't completely make
sense to us but it works so for a
physicist that's fine
for a philosopher they would like to do
a little bit better
the same thing is true with time we have
an understanding of how time works
in a physical way in certain
well-defined circumstances
but there are still philosophical
questions so in this lecture we're going
to sort of
lay out what some of those questions are
and that will help us understand
the scientific aspect that we'll uncover
as we go on through the rest of the
lectures
so what do we mean when we say time
especially as opposed to space what do
we mean when we say
the whole universe when we think of the
universe we generally think of
space we think of not just space as
outer space as planets and stars and
galaxies
but the space around us the location of
things
in the world the world the space that
defines
everything around us and the stuff in
the world
that's what we think of as the universe
but we think of that universe as
happening over and over again so we
automatically right from the start treat
time
and space differently we treat space as
somehow more
important or relevant to what the
universe is
whereas time is just a label that tells
us which moment
of the universe we're talking about
already in lecture one we
discussed this analogy of thinking about
the universe as a movie reel or a film
strip a series of frames a series of
moments
and what i'm trying to say here is that
both each
frame and the whole series
of frames the whole movie reel define
what we think
of as the universe it's this
four-dimensional thing
both space and time and i have to
caution when we use that analogy it's
very tempting to wonder whether or not
like a film strip moments of time are
discrete
as far as we know nothing in physics
tells us that time is discrete as far as
we can tell
time is perfectly smooth and continuous
people
sometimes wonder whether or not a future
reconciliation
between quantum mechanics the theory
that happens at the very small scales
and
relativity einstein's theory of gravity
maybe
someday that will tell us that time
really is discrete after all
quantum mechanics comes from the word
quantum meaning coming in discrete
packets
so maybe when you quantize space and
time itself
they will become in discrete packets but
as far as we know that's not
true their best understanding right now
of time and space
has time being absolutely smooth and
continuous
that's not to say that we will not get a
better understanding of it
in the future but right now i'm not
trying to use the filmstrip analogy
to say that time comes in discrete
packets just that the universe is both
each frame of the movie and the series
of all the frames
together so already the way that that
film strip of the universe works
involves a fairly subtle notion
the continuity of the universe from
moment to moment in time
we said before the universe doesn't
rearrange itself
unlike space so let's sort of
interrogate that
concept a little bit more closely in
space
what happens at this point right here
seems
more or less completely disconnected
from what's happening at this point
right here
now it's true that in the real world
things do not completely change from
point to point in space
here is the air in the room here is the
air in the room also
but i could put you know my hands very
close to the ground and then you would
have air here
and the ground right next to it there's
nothing to stop me
in principle from having absolutely
empty space
at this point and some incredibly dense
or incredibly hot or incredibly
interesting
object right next to it space
the stuff around us and the stuff inside
space
doesn't have any rules about what comes
next to
everything else time on the other hand
has rules about what comes one moment
after the other
that's how the laws of physics work
that's how we think of
the laws of physics in the modern world
and this is not at all
the only possible way the laws of
physics could work this is a really
interesting profound feature of the real
world laws of physics namely that
the way they work is the following you
tell me
what the world is doing right now or at
some other moment of time but you tell
me
everything in the world at one moment in
time
and the laws of physics will tell you
what happens next
and then from that next moment the laws
of physics will tell you what happens
the moment after that
so the laws of physics start from a
moment
start from a state of the universe at
one instance in time
and they tell you using the patterns
using the physics
the equations that are the laws of
physics
what happens at each subsequent moment
that's completely different than space
obviously
in space the laws of physics are not
able to tell you just because something
is happening in this place
what will happen in the place next to it
even when it comes to time
it could have been different remember
aristotle discovered laws of physics
that worked in terms of
the future things have goals and to
understand
what will happen next need to
contemplate what the future conditions
could be
we could contemplate different laws of
physics that involve the past in some
important way
that knowing the universe right now
wasn't enough you needed to know how it
got there
but as a matter of fact the laws of
physics that we use whether they're from
galileo or newton or einstein or
schrodinger or
superstring theory that we talk about
today they all have this feature that
what happens at one moment of time
is enough to predict what will happen at
the next moment of time
and after that you can just keep
predicting all the way toward the future
so to really get our brains wrapped
around this think about the difference
between time and space later on we'll
talk about relativity and how they're
related to each other
but let's for right now just accept the
ordinary notion the time and space are
completely different
uh we move through space as we like we
can choose to go
to some other location in space we can't
choose to go
to some other location in time we
inevitably
move through time at the rate of one
second per second
time is relentless whereas space is sort
of
up to us how to move in it that gives
us a certain perspective on what the
world
is we think of reality as
one moment in time we think that uh
location far away
20 feet away or 20 miles away or 20
million miles away
it might be inaccessible to us right now
but that doesn't mean it's not
real we think of different locations in
space
as absolutely real whether or not we are
there
but now think about time think about the
past and the future
are they real and this is a question
where as soon as you start thinking
about it you begin to suspect
that the answer is just this is not a
good question
to ask nevertheless it's important to
understand
why we think of different times
differently than different
spaces we think of the universe right
now as existing
but we think of the past as over with we
don't think of the past as real in the
same
way that the present is and we certainly
don't think of the future
as just as real so the important thing
is not to figure out
what is real and what is not real the
important thing is to wonder
why do we treat the past and future so
differently why are we thinking of them
in such a different way as we think of
the different parts of space
so to answer that question we should
think about how we use
these concepts how we actually go about
describing
space and time let's imagine you want to
meet someone for coffee you say
let's be at a certain cafe at 6 p.m
what you're really doing is giving them
coordinates in the universe what a
physicist would call an event
you need to specify space where you're
going to meet
and also time when you are going to meet
them
now fortunately we live in a world where
we're basically stuck to the surface of
the earth
so giving someone a coordinate in space
is giving them you know an
address or two numbers let's say what
street you're on and which number you
are on that street
but if you were to meet them anywhere in
space you need to give
three numbers space is three-dimensional
you have
length breadth and height time is
another dimension
on the universe we can marry together
the three dimensions of space
to the one dimension of time to make
something called a four dimensional
space time that space-time is the
collection of all the different
elements in the universe now you might
think that the notion of space-time is
something that einstein
gave us but it's just as important to
think that newton
who preceded einstein could have talked
about space-time
he had space he had time newton knew as
well as einstein did
that to locate someone to meet them
somewhere in the universe
you needed to give four numbers three
locations in space and one
number for what time you would meet them
the difference is that to newton's space
and time were just
so different that there was no
temptation to marry them together you
could have done it
it wouldn't have been against the rules
but there was no benefit
to doing it either einstein as we will
see showed that
what counts as space versus what counts
as time will be different
to different people so you need to think
of them as space time
once you start thinking about the
universe in that way
you hit upon a different possible way of
thinking about the world
our everyday way of thinking about the
world the philosophers would call
presentism presentism is the idea that
what exists what is real
is the three-dimensional universe at
some moment in time
and everything in that universe the past
and the future those are not real the
present moment is real
the past is memory the future is
prediction
but physics suggests a different point
of view
physics says that if i knew the universe
exactly
right now i could predict what the
future would be
and i could also reconstruct what the
past was
the laws of physics connect the present
moment
to the future moments and to the past
moments
so from that perspective we begin to
think that the past
the present and the future maybe are all
equally real
this is a point of view called
eternalism as opposed to presentism
that says the present is real and the
past is a memory of the future is a
prediction
eternalism says all of the moments in
the history of the universe are equally
real
there's nothing special about the
present moment except that you are
experiencing it
right now you might think that there's a
difficult way
of thinking about the world and it is
difficult because it's not our usual way
of going through life sometimes the
point of view of eternalism is called
the block
universe perspective because you try to
imagine
stepping outside of the universe and
seeing the whole
four-dimensional thing as one block of
both space
and time this is sometimes called the
view from nowhen
the view from not any one moment in time
but outside the whole shebang
kurt vonnegut once wrote a novel called
the sirens of titan where he had
characters
aliens called trouth midorians and the
trophy midoriyans had a special feature
that they lived
outside time they experienced the block
universe just as you and i would
experience three-dimensional space
they could choose to you know go to the
year 1600 or go to the year 2500
after breakfast that day now when you
think about it carefully which i know is
not the job of a satirical
science fiction novel but if you were to
think about this very carefully
you'd realize the tralphamadorians don't
quite make
sense we can talk about the
four-dimensional
universe but if you imagine an alien
species that could decide to go
and visit the year 1600 then clearly
they have a personal
notion of time they weren't visiting the
year 1600 yesterday they will be
visiting it tomorrow
so really you're just adding a whole new
dimension of time
to the universe it's a it's something
you can imagine doing
but it's not the universe in which we
live for
us the task is to take ourselves outside
our everyday experience and imagining
looking
at this four-dimensional block universe
to treat
the past present and future on an equal
footing
this seems to be the right way of
looking at things
as suggested by the current laws of
physics i should be honest in saying
that
it's a controversial point of view many
philosophical stances are
controversial there's certainly
philosophers out there who don't believe
in eternalism to me it seems to be the
logical consequence of the physicist's
way
of looking at the universe but it should
be kept in mind that there are other
ways to do it
what does it mean if it is true that the
past present and future
are equally real we certainly think of
them
very differently we treat the future
very differently from the past
another way of thinking about our sort
of folk traditional
everyday way of thinking about the
universe is the growing
block universe model so i said that
presentism treats the present moment as
real the past and future are not real so
a
slight twist on this idea is to treat
the present
and the past as real but the future not
yet
this fits in very well with our notion
that we get to make choices
about the future we don't get to make a
choice about what to have done yesterday
but we get to make a choice about what
to do tomorrow
so the past is fixed it's in the books
it's real we might not be living there
but it happened
it's settled whereas the future is up
for grabs so maybe we should treat them
very very differently
this seems natural to us as human beings
but it has no reflection in the ultimate
laws of physics it is
not something that we get any warrant
for
from our best understanding of the
universe the better way to say it i
believe
is to understand that the reason why we
treat the past and the future so
differently is because of the arrow of
time
in other words it's not time itself that
treats the past and present and future
differently it's the arrow of time
which is ultimately as we will see
depending on the stuff
in the universe on our macroscopic
matter in the configurations that it's
in
in the entropy of the stuff in the
universe that started out low and is
growing and will continue to grow
toward the future it's the arrow of time
that gives us the impression that time
passes the time flows
that we progress through different
moments so from that perspective we
understand that
it's not that the past is more real than
the future it's that we
know more about the past our memories
access moments in the past and when i
say memories i don't just mean
the actual memories in our brains i mean
any
record any fossil anything that we can
look at
that we believe gives us reliable
knowledge about the past
we live in a world where memories exist
where there are history books there are
no history books written
about the future that's the difference
between them which can ultimately be
traced
to the arrow of time so it's not that
the past and the future
don't exist is that we have different
access to them
we were in the past and the memories of
that
past are still reflected in the present
day but that's ultimately because of
entropy growing we'll discuss that in
great detail
but it bears on this question of what is
real and what is not real the answer is
that all moments
of time seem to be real but some we
understand
better than others that's something
we're going to be developing when we get
to the reflection of the arrow of time
and how we think and about how our brain
processes
information so all this is a little bit
philosophical
as we promised so let's get more
concrete about how it plays out
in the everyday world we mentioned that
one way of thinking about time is that
time is what clocks measure we live in a
world
full of clocks and an important thing
about clocks is that time doesn't
simply pass it's not just that there's
earlier and now and later
but that we can measure it we can say
not only has time passed but a certain
amount
of time has passed one second is shorter
than
one minute which is shorter than one day
there is a
amount of time that we can quantify
using clocks
so what a clock is is something that
does the same thing
over and over again in a repeatable way
and then you might ask isn't this whole
thing circular
isn't it that we're defining time as
what clocks measure
and we define clocks that as things that
do the same thing over and over again as
time passes so i want to take the
opportunity to say that it's not a
circular definition there really is some
substance to the claim
that time is what clocks measure a clock
is something that
does the same thing over and over again
but the existence of things that do the
same thing over and over again in a
predictable
way is not taken for granted we might
have lived in a universe
where everything that repeated itself
did so
unpredictably the important feature of
clocks is that there is more than one
clock in our universe we're lucky enough
to live in a universe that is full of
clocks i mean of course that
by clocks something with which we can
measure
the passage of time the earliest clocks
were not on our
wrists or on our computers they were in
the sky
the earth rotates around its axis it
also revolves around the sun
these are two different things that the
earth does
and they do that in a predictable way
they are comparable to
each other roughly speaking the earth
rotates
365 and a quarter times
every time it revolves around the sun
and the nice thing about that is that it
is predictable it's not a different
number of days
per every year it's the same number year
after year after year
that's what makes the motion of the
earth give us reliable clocks and it's
not the only one of course we have the
moon
we have the other planets we have the
stars in the sky the sky gives us
repetitive phenomena that we can use to
measure the passage of time
so you might ask what are the other good
clocks in our universe other than those
that we get in the sky
it's certainly not our memories you know
we experience the passing of time but we
all know
that that experience is not very
reliable sometimes we think a lot of
time has passed other times we're not so
sure we think that very little time has
passed
what we're looking for in a good clock
is something that can be relied on that
does the same thing
over and over again obviously the
rotation of revolution of the earth is
an obvious choice
another one is the rocking of a pendulum
back and forth that is why we put
pendulums in our grandfather clocks
these days on our wrist watches the best
clocks will be in the form of quartz
crystals you can actually make a certain
quartz crystal in the shape of a tuning
fork
that is guaranteed to vibrate back and
forth exactly 32
768 times per second
the reason why that number is chosen is
because it is 2 to the power of 15.
so you can take 32 768
and divide it by 2 15 times you can
divide the time periods up
as finely as you want to quartz is both
reliable and predictable it won't matter
what the humidity is what the
temperature is
that quartz crystal will tell you the
time to very high accuracy
this search for reliable clocks isn't
always
an easy one let's go back to the idea of
the pendulum
rocking back and forth it turns out to
be true
that the rocking of a pendulum is a
pretty good clock but it's certainly not
obvious you might think that if the
pendulum was just moving a little bit
maybe it goes faster than if it's moving
a lot
this was actually shown not to be the
case all the way back in 1583 by
none other than galileo he was a young
boy he was going to church like all
young boys in pisa in italy did at that
period of time but occasionally he would
get bored sitting around in church and
because he was galileo
he did little mental science experiments
so galileo noticed there was a
chandelier hanging from the ceiling of
the cathedral in pisa which is still
there you can visit it today
and the chandelier rocked back and forth
and sometimes it was only rocking a
little bit
sometimes some air had disturbed it and
it was rocking a little bit more
and galileo got the idea in his head
that it seemed
that the amount of time it took the
chandelier to go back and forth was the
same
no matter what the amplitude of the
rocking was the time
was approximately the same the question
is how would he check
this idea he was an empiricist he wants
to do an experiment
to figure out whether this idea is on
the right track and again because he's
galileo
he realized he could compare the rocking
of the chandelier to the beating of his
heart
galileo calculated that he could count
his pulse while he was watching the
chandelier go back and forth and what he
realized is that
his conjecture was correct that no
matter what the
amount of rocking was the frequency
the time it took the pendulum to go back
and forth the chandelier hanging from
the ceiling
it was going to be the same this is the
basis we have for pendulum clocks
even today it's not the absolute most
reliable way of telling time we have
but for the 16th century it was a very
very good step forward
we still use that way of timekeeping
today
you can imagine like we said a different
world a world in which there were no
regularities that there were no such
good clocks anywhere in the universe
there were things that happened over and
over again
but they happened at unpredictable rates
compared to each other
this would be a very strange world to
live in it would be completely crazy
from our point of view
it's a world in which you couldn't
measure the passage of time there would
be no reliable clocks
there would still be time there could
still be the idea that there was a
moment
before some other moment but you could
never say how much time had passed
from one moment to the other so in a way
we're very fortunate at least
scientists are very fortunate that we
live in a world where time can be
measured
a world in which clocks exist and we can
build them and they will tell us how
much time has passed
the reason why clocks are so important
when we think about time is because
they give us an operational way of
thinking about time you can easily get
yourself
mixed up thinking about the fundamental
nature of time
and clocks help us because they refer to
things that really happen not just to
abstract
concepts so questions like are the past
and the future
equally real may or may not be
interesting questions but you can ask
what would a clock do that's an
interesting question that gives you an
answer one way or another
so consider for example a favorite
thought experiment
what if time were to simply stop what if
time ceased passing everywhere in the
universe
or alternatively but just as well what
if time
slowed down everywhere in the universe
what would that
mean i'll give you time to think about
it the answer is
it would mean absolutely nothing if time
stops everywhere for everything in the
universe
there would be no way of knowing you
would stop the processes in your brain
would stop your pulse would stop
your breathing would stop so you would
not experience any time at all because
time has stopped
but at the same time all of the clocks
would stop the earth would stop rotating
the pendulum would stop rocking back and
forth
so when you compared the amount of time
felt by any one
object in the universe to the amount of
time experienced by any other object
in the universe time stopping everywhere
leaves no trace whatsoever while i am
lecturing to you right now you might
imagine the time has stopped
and you'd never know but then you
realize that if time has stopped you
can't even say well
time has stopped for one century that
doesn't mean anything
because time has stopped so when you get
lost in these questions about the
meaning of time
what is real and what is not real it
always is helpful to go
back to what do clocks do there's a
story
that illustrates this very well there's
a novel written by nicholson baker
called the fermata it's about a man who
can stop
time he just has a magical ability it's
not explained it's not hard science
fiction or anything like that
here is just a person who can decide to
stop time
whenever he wants to but obviously he's
not stopping time
everywhere in the universe he himself
keeps time
going if you read the novel which is a
good read it's interesting and
thought-provoking
the man himself is not an admirable
character he mostly uses his ability to
sort of
make people look foolish in different
ways he's not saving the world
but we as scientists can ask we're
philosophers
what would it mean for someone to be
able to stop time well how would that
really work forgetting about
could you do it forgetting about the
technology problem of how you would
build a time stopping machine
what would actually happen if you could
stop time for the rest of the universe
while you yourself kept going
well you would quickly realize that even
if you grant
the possibility of such a thing it
doesn't actually work like it says it
would work in the novel
for one thing if you stop time for the
rest of the world let's say everything
more than
three feet away from you time stops
suddenly you can't see anything
more than three feet away from you
there's no light coming to you
from any of those things that are
outside your time stopping zone because
time has stopped
you cannot breathe anymore if the air in
the room has stopped moving
if you started to move through the air
and these other air molecules
are absolutely stationary they would be
a brick wall
to you you could not even walk in such a
room
so when you actually sit down to think
about what it means
to stop time or even for time to move at
different rates for different people
it's actually a very very slippery
notion
we will later see when we talk about
relativity that there is a well-defined
scientific sense in which different
people can measure
time moving at different speeds but the
only way they can do that is by
being in different places in the
universe or moving through the universe
at different
rates of good old-fashioned velocity if
you're stuck near a black hole
or if you're in a spaceship moving very
very close to the speed of light
then the amount of time that passes on
your wristwatch
will be different than the amount of
time experienced by someone
who stayed back at home but if you're
looking at your wristwatch it will seem
to move at the absolute conventional
rate because you
and your watch any clocks you bring
along with you all are traveling
together
you all experience the same passage of
time
i think that in some ways in the modern
world time has a bad reputation we feel
that we are
slaves to the passage of time that
there's a clock there is a calendar we
have to get things done there are
deadlines and they get in our way
but if you think about it all of these
aspects of time
are social the reason why time presses
on us
is because we are trying to coordinate
with the outside world
we have a clock someone else has a clock
we agreed to meet
for coffee at the same place at the same
time time is only
pressing us when we want to match our
actions in the world with the actions of
somebody else i would argue that it's
not
fundamentally a bad thing we should not
blame time for this
we should be grateful we live in a world
that lets us coordinate and be social
[Music]
creatures
[Music]
you